good morning John hey look it's Portland
Oregon outside that window also in this
hotel room I can't I mean what is space
I'm up in the air 14 stories and inside
of a hotel room that is owned by I
assume a hotel chain am I even in any of
those places am I not just in the space
between my neurons is that Portland is
that area between my neurons Portland
just because I am within the boundaries
of the city of Portland Oregon booth as
you might be able to tell just by the
conversation I just had with you I've
been hanging out with the creators of
welcome to night Vale Joseph Fink and
Jeffrey Cranor their book just came out
debuted number four on the New York
Times bestseller list number four
because Nicholas Sparks JK Rowling and
John Grisham all came out with new books
bad week to try and get to number one I
was with Jeffrey and Joseph when they
got the news that they were number four
in the New York Times bestseller list
and that was a great experience for me
not only because the Chinese crepes from
the Portland food cart we were eating
were amazing but also because it was
good to see that happen to a person I'm
feeling very thankful right now I'm
feeling thankful for like three or four
things just great comments on the last
couple videos that we've made remarkable
how well received my Benghazi video was
I got lots of hate just to be clear but
like the like to dislike ratio was
amazing which makes me feel like there's
just there's a lot of interest in this
kind of content I mean it doesn't go
super viral let's be honest if my video
was about getting riled up and angry
about one or the other side how wrong
they were how evil they were how they
were trying to destroy America and this
is literally the rhetoric that people
use in these conversations it would have
gotten more views it would have made
people want to stand up on the
mountaintops and shout to their people
and it would have gotten more than
300,000 views but 300,000 views it's a
tremendous amount it's the kind of
influence that high school or college
Hank could only have ever dreamed of
having
what is the goal what is the important
thing here that we use the platform we
have to get more views to grow a bigger
platform and then we use that platform
to grow a bigger platform and then that
bigger platform we can then use to grow
a bigger platform is that the only goal
at a certain point you have to say like
doing things that you know as a person
are bad for individual people and
culture as a whole are not worth doing
just to get a bigger audience and
instead you use the platform you have
then god am i grateful to have this
platform to do something you think is
good and I think making content that
removes the charge that removes the fear
of the other 50% of Americans from the
political discourse that would be
extremely valuable I also want to say
thanks to all the people who left really
positive constructive fascinating
comments on John's YouTube red video I
just installed YouTube red I love I'm
just like digging not having
advertisements there's the 30 a 30 day
free trial signed up for it and it's a
it's a dream honestly it's just me and
my subscriptions it's nice I get what
all those people who have ad blockers
installed I understand why you do it
I've never done it because it's
literally how I pay my employees so it
would feel a little bad about that but I
totally understand at the moment John
I'm just I'm inspired to do things that
I think are cool or interesting that I
think people will like that's that's
really I guess that's all we've ever
wanted to do and we get to do it we're
so lucky thanks everybody John I'll see
you on Tuesday I had a whole lot of
pizza before I had made this video I do
not feel great feel less than great